welcome back everyone its charlie we
have new Star Wars Episode 9 the rise
of Skywalker footage to breakdown and we
have early reviews of the Mandalorian
series so we'll break it all down
because tickets are going sale on Monday
I'll do a giveaways for movie tickets
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite Star
Wars moment on the video we'll start
with all the new footage then we'll talk
about the Mandalorian reviews there were
three separate new teasers starting with
kylo ren's new TIE fighter based on the
tie advanced flying through the desert
it's probably part of that same scene
that we saw in the very first trailer
when Ray gets ready to jump over it
there's a bunch of new Thai fighter
designs in the movie this should not be
confused with a new Thai whisper this is
actually a one-sheet of all the new
character designs and the new ship
designs if you're big toy collector this
also kind of reads like an instruction
manual these are all the new toys that
you need to buy based on the new movie
kylo Ren's TIE fighter based on an
improvement of the Thai advanced design
Darth Vader used in the original trilogy
of course Darth Vader fanboy who based
his look and his helmet on Darth Vader's
designs would do the same thing copying
a lot of elements from the design of
Darth Vader's TIE fighter there's the
smaller Sith Thai fighter coloured red
to match the red sits troopers armor
I'll talk about them in a second because
it seems like Emperor Palpatine has
something waiting in the wings in this
crazy force looking storm with all these
classic looking star destroyers and
classic looking TIE fighter designs
modified for all the Syst troopers
there's the regular old TIE fighters
just recolored if it's not broke don't
fix it
oldies but goodies there's a Special
Forces TIE fighter from the more
hardcore type pilots more weaponry more
maneuverability and then the newer Thai
whisper which is the same basic idea is
a Special Forces TIE fighter but they've
silenced the classic TIE fighter howling
sound that the engines make just made
for more stealth missions there's a
bunch of other designs here that we
could talk about including the Knights
of Ren I'll cover them in just a second
too they're probably going to be more
footage of them in the next big trailer
the other footage seems like it comes
from really early in the movie ray
saying goodbye to Leia maybe for the
last time on this end or inspired force
planet just based on what they said and
what we know about Leia scenes in the
movie the way they cut that first big
trailer with Luke's force ghost voice
over talking to Ray about how they were
passing on their legacy to the younger
characters while Leia was hugging her it
just gave the scene a sense of finale
is all because Carrie Fisher
unfortunately passed away before they
shot the movie they said that they used
a lot of digital effects wizardry to
turn Leia's deleted scenes from the
force awakens in two seemingly new
scenes during Episode 9
so what won't be that uncanny valley
digital version of Leia that they did
for rogue one it'll be real Carrie
Fisher in the flesh they just
photoshopped the real Carrie Fisher
footage into this scene this looks like
it's just Rey Chewie finn poe and c-3po
and the next scene right after that Leia
goodbye scene climbing into the Falcon
to take it to this very Tatooine
inspired desert planet arriving at this
new nomadic city even though they shot a
lot of the desert stuff for jakku in
jordan and this was shot in jordan on
these desert planet scenes I believe
it's meant to be a new planet that we
haven't been to before but they haven't
confirmed that yet just for reference
all the desert scenes from Episode four
in Return of the Jedi were shot in
Tunisia so even though it looks very
similar it's shot in a very different
place clearly you can tell though
thematically how they're mirroring
the movements of the original trilogy
for instance in Episode four you start
on Tatooine a desert planet at the end
of that trilogy in Return of the Jedi
you wind up back on Tatooine in the
desert there's nothing to see ice
delivery then the force awakens you
start on a desert planet jakku and now
in the final film you seemingly find
yourself back on a desert planet whether
or not it's jakku how much they're
mirroring the movements of the original
trilogy remains to be seen but there is
a lot of mirroring to Return of the Jedi
on purpose of course we find ourselves
on an end or looking forest planet noe
walks in sight though we find them going
back to the wreckage of the second Death
Star from Return of the Jedi and Emperor
Palpatine is back Q Darth Plagueis the
wise explainer you ever hear the tragedy
of Darth Plagueis the wise I know a lot
of you are asking if Anakin Skywalker is
going to have a cameo during the movie I'll
address that in a second because it was
some weird stuff that Lucasfilm did
earlier this year not allowing Hayden
Christensen to go to a Comic Con panel
like why would you prevent him from
doing a comic-con panel if you didn't
want him to accidentally not give
anything away I've seen a lot of
everyone's Palpatine theories and a lot
of Dark Jedi Rey theories I still think
that all this dark raise seems
that we saw in the last trailer is meant
to be a vision of a potential future
that could happen should Emperor
Palpatine be successful in coming back
in early speculation I do think the
emperor palpatine essence is trying to
inhabit someone's body so that he can
physically come back from death just
like during the dark empire comic series
during the 90s if you haven't read that
it's fantastic but technically it's not
Canada anymore
he's trying to enter one of the clones
must destroy them all the reason why
everyone keeps going back to the dark
empire theory for all this new rise of
Skywalker stuff is because of a couple
specific shots that we saw during the
last big trailer during the dark empire
comic Emperor Palpatine made contingency
plans for his return he has large stores
and warehouses hidden all over the
galaxy with Sith artifacts Jedi
artifacts one of the biggest and most
important ones is deep in the galactic
core on the planet Biss a planet that's
very strong in the dark side of the
force he has a hidden Armada with a
special super weapon it wouldn't be Star
Wars if there wasn't a special new super
weapon in every different series he also
has hundreds and hundreds of younger
cloned versions of himself around the
age of 18 so he's basically trying to
transfer his force consciousness after
the events of Return of the Jedi into a
younger version of himself one of the
way for some more footage in that next
trailer to see if they confirm any of
these theories but I'm not expecting
that to copy-paste any specific
storyline most of the biggest twist and
force abilities are all covered during
that stuff and slowly what they've done
with new Star Wars is reconized
a lot of the expanded universe they've
also done the same thing during the
Mandalorian series bringing some stuff
back into the Canon even though the
footage they've given us so far is cut
in a very confusing way to try and
mislead you I'm getting all these Return
of the Jedi flashbacks watching it and
until they give us a bunch more footage
my expectations are that the ending will
be a twist on the ending of Return of
the Jedi where Vader tried to kill the
Emperor but maybe this time kylo Ren
will be successful
redemption of Ben's solo I think that's
what most people are expecting there'll
be some sort of redemption for kylo Ren
who is also part Skywalker by blood
the rise of Skywalker but addressing the
Anakin Skywalker cameos because we
haven't had Hayden Christensen involve
in the new trilogy that much a lot of
people are expecting that because this
is the final film of the Skywalker
trilogy in Darth Vader Anakin Skywalker
is such a big part of the Skywalker saga
story that they will find room for him
to cameo either as a force ghost or in
some other way but now talking about the
early Mandalorian reviews they screened
about 30 minutes of footage from the
first episode for critics everyone was
going crazy about it it's all the
feedback that you want to hear about a
new Star Wars series most of what I've
seen is that classic Star Wars fans are
really hyped up about what they're doing
with the Mandalorian because by design
it's made to be very classic Star Wars
it's taking place five years after
Return of the Jedi so it's before the
rise of the first-order they just
invited a bunch of journalists to a news
conference where they screened all this
footage and during that they revealed
that they've already started the first
week of filming on season two of the
Mandalorian so they've already renewed
it and it sounds like they're going
premiere season two next year around
this same time which i think is great
that it's back on a regular schedule
I've seen a little confusion in the
comments on the Mandalorian trailer
videos because obviously he's doing the
Boba Fett thing where you never see him
take his helmet off at least in the
trailers we'll probably see him do it
during the series a lot of people are
confused about who that is
so if you didn't watch the first teaser
he actually speaks during that it's
Pedro Pascal that's playing the
Mandalorian character you don't know
what his actual name is they just call
him the Mandalorian which is a riff on
the classic spaghetti westerns like
Clint Eastwood's man with no name he
actually does have a name but it's not
like characters in his movies walk
around saying his name all the time
they're also spinning up to shoot the
Star Wars obi-wan Kenobi Disney Plus
series early next year there's no
release date for that yet so they could
drop it at any point I have a feeling
though that they'll try to drop it
during a different part of the year
because it'll also probably be about
eight episodes which is what the
Mandalorian is if you're a big fan of
dave felonious Clone Wars and all the
rebels stuff he also teased that we
would see characters from the Clone Wars
animated series appeared during the
live-action series he didn't say Ahsoka
was going to show up
he said just wait and see so that pretty
much confirms that we would be seeing
some classic characters come back I will
be doing episode videos and Easter eggs
for it but this is the full episode
schedule so the first episode drops when
Disney Plus launches November 12th
that's on a Tuesday but then the rest of
episodes for the most part will air on
Fridays they didn't say what time on
Fridays they would be releasing those
episodes but it'll be the same time for
the most part for everyone that has
access to Disney Plus and if for some
reason it hasn't rolled out in your
country yet then I would just recommend
you look for another way quote-unquote
to watch it they move the date for
Episode seven just so that it doesn't
conflict with the theatrical release of
Star Wars Episode 9 but for the most
part it's once a week every Friday
everyone post your reactions in the
comments below I will name a giveaway
winner when I do my next big Star Wars
Episode 9 trailer video Monday night
so look out for that as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
that video when I post it everybody
click here for that last big Star Wars
Episode 9 trailer video and click
here for the Avengers infinity Saga
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight